now let's jump to texas which reported
129
covet related deaths yesterday the
state's largest one-day
death toll so far the number of new
cases topped the 10
000 mark on the same day and houston is
now getting help from teams of doctors
and nurses
sent by the u.s army and by new york
state janet chamberlin spoke to a young
icu nurse recovering from covet
and a doctor who compares the outbreak
there to a war zone
how heartbreaking is this for you oh my
god man i
i tell you i was a flight surgeon in the
iraq war
but it's very different when the person
that you're
putting in a body bag is your next door
neighbor for 50 years your mom's best
friend
dr ivan melendez paints a picture of a
health care system in
chaos as beds fill up things are so dire
that people are being
resuscitated on stretchers in the
hallways the night before last i had
four calls of four patients dying
the governor says patients under 30 are
a driving force
behind the latest surge in cases it's
really important to take every symptom
very seriously because i could have
ended up in a very bad condition
twenty-four-year-old houston intensive
care nurse heather valentine came down
with covett
and was just released from the hospital
this week she was lucky enough to have a
room with a window
where her parents could visit unable to
touch
they pressed hands against the glass how
frightened were your parents
my mom this has been her worst nightmare
since you know i'm on the front lines
and i work with
you know people with coved she's been
you know so scared for me
it's become a very personal and
unfortunate experience
dr melendez who also recovered from
covid
says emotions run high for patients
their loved ones
and the doctors and nurses on the front
lines
you know i think you can imagine that
all of us cry every day every day they
cry
and they're angry
dr melendez says that six nurses that
he's worked with
have died of covet and he says at his
hospital they're doing the best they can
right now to make more beds available
for those coronavirus patients
gail a very sad situation down there in
the valley
i'll say janet the doctor i think really
puts it in perspective when he says it's
very different when you have to put your
next door neighbor
your best friend's mom in a body bag i
don't know what it's going to take for
people to understand how serious this is
thank you very much